en vídeos anteriores vimos que la
fotosíntesis se puede dividir en las
reacciones dependientes de la luz y el
ciclo de calvin y las reacciones
dependientes de la luz es donde se toma
la luz junto con el agua y veremos que
el agua es en realidad una fuente de
electrones y podemos usar eso para
almacenar energía en forma de atp y enea
de ph y como subproducto obtenemos
oxígeno molecular el cual es muy
importante para que nosotros podamos
respirar y entonces el atp y el nh se
pueden utilizar en el ciclo de calvin
junto con dióxido de carbono para
sintetizar azúcar en este vídeo nos
vamos a centrar en las reacciones
dependientes de la luz como ocurre este
proceso y para ayudarnos a pensar en
esto vamos a hacer un acercamiento a una
membrana de los ti la coidh es este es
un tila coi de justo aquí se encuentra
en el interior del cloroplasto y si
hacemos un acercamiento a su membrana
podemos ver que es una de capa de
fosfolípidos al igual que muchas
pero no es que vemos en biología y a
primera vista este diagrama puede
parecer muy complejo y eso es porque es
un diagrama complejo y a menudo vas a
ver dibujos como este en tus libros de
biología pueden ser muy intimidantes
estas proteínas moléculas y complejos
tienen nombres que pueden sonar muy
complicados pero la idea general de lo
que está pasando y espero que encuentres
esta explicación bastante sencilla
tenemos la energía luminosa o energía
lumínica los fotones de la luz vana ya
sea directamente o indirectamente
excitar a los electrones esos electrones
excitados están en un estado de alta
energía y van a ser transferidos de una
molécula a otra y van a pasar a estados
de energía más bajos eso es lo que
permite que estas transferencias ocurran
de manera espontánea que van desde un
estado de alta energía a un estado de
menor energía los electrones están cada
vez más y más cómodos
y parte de esa energía que se libera
conforme el electrón pasa de un estado
de alta energía a un estado de menor
energía se utiliza para bombear iones de
hidrógeno a través de la membrana dentro
del lumen y la coidh al así que se está
formando un gradiente de concentración
de iones de hidrógeno
gradiente
d
concentración
de iones de hidrógeno
donde hay una mayor concentración en el
interior que en el exterior y esto por
sí mismo este gradiente de concentración
como veremos se puede utilizar para
estimular la producción de atp por medio
de la atp cintas a esos iones de
hidrógeno quieren volver a salir ellos
quieren ir a favor del gradiente de
concentración y conforme salen a través
de la atp sin tasa esencialmente se
acciona el motor que enlaza a un grupo
fosfato con la molécula de bp para
producir atp
así que una manera de pensar en ello es
que se está produciendo un gradiente de
iones de hidrógeno lo podríamos escribir
así gradiente de
h más
que es utilizado para producir atp
ahora los electrones que van de un
estado de alta energía a un estado de
menor energía en esta parte de las
reacciones dependientes de la luz no es
lo único que está contribuyendo al
gradiente de concentración de iones de
hidrógeno
una vez que el electrón es donado
podrías preguntarte cómo es reemplazado
ese electrón bueno la cosa que está
donando ese electrón es una variación de
la clorofila a llamada de 680 la p se
refiere a pigmento y 680 se refiere a
680 nanómetros la longitud de onda de
luz que absorbe mejor y así cuando entra
en un estado excitado y se hace
referencia a ello con la anotación de
680 asterisco denotando que tiene un
electrón excitado y una vez que dona su
electrón se convierte en
de 680 con una carga positiva y a este
peso 680 lo podríamos llamar p 680 más o
tal vez unión de peso y cientos 80 este
es un agente oxidante muy fuerte uno de
los más fuertes si no es que el más
fuerte que conocemos en los sistemas
biológicos por lo que le gusta tomar
electrones de otras cosas y la sustancia
que está alrededor de la cual puede
tomar electrones es el agua
este es un agente oxidante tan fuerte
que puede oxidar al oxígeno en el agua y
si tomamos en cuenta que la palabra
oxidar proviene de la palabra oxígeno
debido a que el oxígeno es tan electro
negativo que es un agente oxidante muy
fuerte es decir normalmente el oxígeno
es el que oxida a las demás sustancias
no el que es oxidado así que la ape 680
más toma un electrón del agua y luego el
agua se separa por lo que nos quedamos
con el oxígeno y por acá con los iones
de hidrógeno y esos iones de hidrógeno
también contribuyen a la alta
concentración de iones de hidrógeno en
el interior
y aquí es donde obtenemos al oxígeno
como un subproducto
y aquí tenemos una mitad de una molécula
de o2 por lo que si hacemos esto dos
veces vamos a tener un oxígeno molecular
hasta ahora hemos hablado de cómo se
produce el oxígeno hemos hablado de cómo
se produce el atp pero qué pasa con el
ndp h
hemos comenzado nuestro proceso en el
foto sistema 2 y podrías preguntarte por
qué se le llama foto sistema 2 si es ahí
por donde empezamos bueno en realidad se
debe a que es el segundo foto sistema en
ser descubierto
podrías preguntar que es un foto sistema
estos fotos sistemas y complejos son
combinaciones de proteínas y moléculas y
este foto sistema en particular tiene
clorofila y variaciones de la molécula
de clorofila y pigmentos que son
sensibles a la luz que tienen electrones
que pueden conseguir un estado excitado
por medio de la luz y pueden transferir
esa energía de vuelta al par de
clorofila a bs 680
entonces pueden tener su electrón en
estado excitado y se lo puede dar a una
molécula receptora y luego se puede ir a
estados de energía más bajos y bombear
esos iones de hidrógeno hacia adentro
pero esas no son todas las reacciones
dependientes de la luz ese electrón
puede llegar al fotosistema 1 y porque
se llama fotosistema 1 bueno porque fue
el primero en ser descubierto
en el foto sistema 1 hay otro par de
clorofila ha denominado p 700 y esto es
debido a que absorben de manera óptima
luz con longitud de onda de 700
nanómetros y ocurre algo similar la luz
puede ya sea directa o indirectamente
excitar a su electrón y entonces ese
electrón conforme va a un nivel de
energía menor y pasa de una molécula a
otra puede ser utilizado para reducir
ndp más en n a dp h así que de ahí viene
el ndp h y luego una vez que la pst
cientos accedido su electrón quiere un
electrón y puede conseguirlo del
electrón que ha estado yendo cada vez a
estados de energía más bajos y lo
podemos ver como el electrón que ha
estado viajando desde el foto sistema 2
y por eso es que por lo general vemos
estos diagramas en los libros de
biología la luz entra los electrones
energizan
en un estado excitado y van a estados de
energía más y más bajos
conforme hacen eso están siendo
transferidos de una molécula a otra y
este proceso está siendo facilitado por
enzimas esa energía o parte de esa
energía está siendo utilizada para
transferir los iones de hidrógeno al
lumen y la coidh al al interior
luego en el foto sistema 1 el electrón
de la p 700 entra en un estado excitado
y la pesa 300 puede agarrar el electrón
que pasó a estados de energía más bajos
y su electrón excitado puede ser
transferido de una molécula a otra con
el fin de suministrar energía para que
el ndp más se ha convertido en enea de
ph y una vez más la idea del incremento
en la concentración de iones de
hidrógeno aquí puede alimentar a la atp
sin tasa lo que nos permite enlazar un
grupo fosfato a la molécula de adp para
producir
así que ahí es donde conseguimos todas
estas cosas y el subproducto por
supuesto es nuestro oxígeno y si quieres
ver la misma idea pero sólo desde el
punto de vista energético sin toda la
complejidad de ver a todos los
componentes físicos implicados lo
podemos ver aquí donde la energía de la
luz viene excita los electrones y una
vez que el pez 680 ha donado ese
electrón quiere un electrón y lo obtiene
del agua y conforme el electrón va a
estados de energía cada vez más bajos
finalmente puede ser agarrado por la p
700 que ha cedido su propio electrón y
ese electrón que había sido excitado en
la p 700 por la energía luminosa puede
ser transferido de una molécula a otra
para impulsar la creación de enea de ph
y esta fase por aquí
conforme el electrón pasa de un estado
de alta energía a un estado de baja
energía
alimenta el bombeo de protones de
hidrógeno dentro de ti la coidh